a controversy got started on twitter
just recently with a thread sometimes
called the thread about academic life
by a professor danielle dick who is
currently at rutgers which she joined in
january 2022
going there getting full tenure also
being appointed as the inaugural
director of the rutgers addiction
research center
and leaving
virginia commonwealth university so
here's what she said that caught a lot
of people's attention
she began her thread by saying
my feed is full of people leaving
academia for industry i'm not saying
academia is perfect but i love being a
professor and i think academia can be a
wonderful career option a thread on why
then she followed that up saying
compared to many other careers as a
faculty member you get to be your own
boss as long as you're productive no one
is looking over your shoulder constantly
often you check in with your supervisor
for review only once a year you have
tremendous freedom
great work life balance you can take off
as needed to be there for kids schools
activities and other things you want to
do as long as you're getting your stuff
done no one is scrutinizing what hours
you work
it's fun you choose what you're working
on and get to pursue questions that are
interesting to you
smart colleagues academia is full of
really interesting people who are
passionate about a wide variety of
topics you have access to a wealth of
expertise and all the interesting
learning opportunities that come with
seminars classes etc
it doesn't get boring you can adapt what
you're working on and change your focus
over time teaching training grants
leadership opportunities administration
you can change your job without changing
your job and that keeps things
interesting and stimulating
i know that everyone's experience is
unique and i won't pretend there aren't
real problems in academia discrimination
low pay in certain positions pressure to
bring in grants challenging colleagues
or supervisors everyone weighs the pros
and cons differently
this is where you might hear like a
record scratch if i was doing sound
effects in here and let's take a look at
what some people said right off the bat
so
this reads like satire then somebody
else wrote the fact it's been up for
three days with no indication of
self-reflection on the part of the
author is really something
another uh truly amazing someone can put
out a five-tweet thread about how great
academia is
without not even once engaging with what
the actual problems are now of course
you could say well she did mention that
there are some problems but it's an
overly rosy picture isn't it that
professor dick is sketching out
mark writes here dr dick is rightly
getting dragged for this there's nothing
wrong with loving your job as an
academic i do
but a post that completely ignores the
abundant injustice
abuse and crushing hardship that so many
face amounts to little more than let
them eat cake now if you're not an
academic and you're going by
portrayals of academia in the popular
media that we've seen like on tv shows
or talking heads on on various you know
politics shows you might actually be
forgiven for not understanding what
these people are talking about
things are pretty difficult in academia
and they have been for the majority of
academics at least here in america for
decades
here's another interesting response
please consider deleting this it's the
worst possible time
to trumpet the wonderful option that
most people trying to be academics will
never have and we'll talk about that in
just a moment
now daniel dick did also you know follow
this up um and she finished her thread
by saying i also think that having more
academics in the private sector is a
good thing but i wanted to point out
some of the wonderful parts of being in
academia as well and then you know
several days later
four days later to be precise she said i
want to add context since this thread
has been circulated widely in a way i
never expected let's let's stop there
for a moment
this is a very very tone-deaf thread by
somebody who has really lucked out in
many respects and
comes across to
most of the fellow academics on twitter
who had something to say about this as
extraordinarily lucky
privileged and almost willfully ignorant
about what her
she might not even consider them
colleagues in academia face so she goes
on and she says it was in response to
comments specifically by colleagues in
my field who were deciding between
higher paid jobs in industry versus
taking a tenure tech track job at a
research one university now isn't that a
delightful option to have higher paid
jobs in industry or a tenure track job
at a research one university if you do
have that option that's pretty awesome
for you
now
here's some
follow-ups to it
you are what your watch says
i wasn't going to engage with this tweet
because it's just what only a well-paid
tenure track academic would say and then
i became actually curious
if you think most people were leaving
academia by choice and not material
necessity an option implies
reasonable choices
not tragic dilemmas and so that i think
is a very
important
point to make along with this
jeanette smith says thought this was a
joke tweet to begin with i loved
academia and it was a great career
option but job security is denied to so
many
most people leaving are not doing so out
of choice but because they can't afford
to stay with the insecurity this is the
present day reality and the reality from
the past decades it's not a completely
new thing
for most academics if you look at these
statistics most academics are not
tenured let alone even tenure track most
are in precarious
positions let's follow up about rutgers
itself suzanne boswell says there are
wonderful things about being a professor
but most people teaching in academia
aren't professors they're adjuncts
professor how many adjuncts work at
rutgers how many adjuncts were fired
from rutgers during the pandemic just
out of curiosity there was no response
of course
but she wrote i will answer this
question myself before the pandemic 3000
ptls taught at rutgers these are
part-timers
25 of them were fired they were not
their own boss they did not set their
own working hours
many of them were just as if not more
qualified as any rutgers faculty member
and this is a a big problem within
academia whether somebody has a
tenure-track job or not depends on very
contingent matters
those who get them often act as if
they're better than everybody else when
really if you look closely at the level
of teaching
or even research
many of the tenure track people are not
particularly
shining you could say
here's a bunch of other responses
that all have a common theme
no one is disputing that things look
pretty good from your lofty heights the
issue is that many of us on precarious
contracts will never get there and those
of us with disabilities or caring
responsibilities or no economic support
have even less of a chance of securing
tenure now think back to what dick said
about oh you know you could just take
off if you want to go to a child's event
or something like that that may be the
reality for her that's not the reality
for many people working in academia
somebody else writes this is basically i
don't understand why people have money
problems why don't they just win the
lottery like i did and that's a valid
response i think
i'm not sure if this one is true or not
but it's worth considering from uh
melanie helped this is 100 a faculty who
relies on staff whom she addresses as
folks to do all the invisible labor of
making a department run and also doesn't
know how to operate the copier now
whether professor dick is that person i
think that all of us in academia have
met those people and there's there's i
wouldn't say a hundred percent chance
but let's i don't know rate it 80 to 90
percent
um here's a typical response by somebody
who has worked as an adjunct i had to
work as an adjunct at two different
schools on opposite sides of the twin
cities metro area because neither had
the funding for for a full-time tenured
professor
between the two i wasn't guaranteed work
the following year always afraid the
department would be cut
only had part-time adjunct benefits not
protected tenured benefits no office
space at one of the schools had to meet
students for office hours in the library
part-time status meant i didn't know
school procedures well enough to help
students navigate issues i think anybody
who's taught as an adjunct can relate to
some of this adjunct benefits oh that's
nice if you've got them most places
don't have adjunct benefits you're paid
poorly you don't have any sort of job
security if a full-timer decides that
they want your class they'll steal it
from you sometimes just weeks before the
semester begins
here's another one from disabled doctor
some of us don't leave academia for
industry willingly in academia can be
incredibly inaccessible to many for a
variety of reasons so glad you are able
to make it work but to assume others
need a description of your privileged
situation is kind of an odd take
continuing on here's some other posts
and responses that i think are pretty on
point
althea says yes we know academia can be
like this which is why many of us worked
so hard to get a phd
the fact is only the lucky end up in
those positions so this genre of tweet
feels incredibly condescending to anyone
who has not been so lucky or who has
faced real barriers
melatonin says posting about how
wonderful it is to have a stable career
in academia is like posting how great it
is to be a wealthy german duchess like
yes i'm sure that's great for you my
liege and you know the rate of uh
tenure track positions opening up is
declining uh over the years and it's not
quite so so bad as this is making it out
to be but it's pretty close and that's
where this other one comes in
food and service was great and crew
manning the lifeboat lovely 4 out of 5
stars only because luggage got slightly
wet reviewed by first class passenger of
the titanic
implying that academia is kind of going
down and
in some respects it is
here's a good point made about the
provincialism of this tweet
this thread
much of this threat is relevant to the
usa and possibly only research
universities there now i'm going to
pause and say and possibly only to those
who are lucky enough to have the tenure
track positions in research universities
there and don't encounter any real
problems in doing so he goes on and says
in the uk for example and to a lesser
extent australia autonomy has been
eroded with an ever-growing list of kpis
dictated by whatever are the
institutions current strategic
priorities that is the case i mean if
you've been watching paying attention to
what's going on in academia and other
places
you don't have the freedom of maneuver
you might say right
isabelle says maybe where you are there
is a work-life balance your choice of
research does not depend on what is
fashionable you can focus on teaching if
you want there's enough money to have
fun and bullying isn't the norm and
maybe expectations are achievable
lucky you
simon says in many ways the thread in
the comments some academia up and and
how so well you know you've got some
very privileged people weighing in and
then you've got the rest of us the the
unwashed masses saying yeah things
aren't quite so rosy as you're saying so
in principle it can be a fantastic
career with many of the benefits you
mentioned the reality is sadly often
very different i'm very lucky where i
currently work but i've also been in
some incredibly toxic environments in
those workplaces i saw significant
workplace bullying unrealistic work
expectations lack of work-life balance
discrimination of various forms poor pay
and benefits pressure on what to
research lack of effective management
job insecurity work related health
issues etc so you know
some factors that are well worth taking
in
now here's another set of responses that
focus on how much academia has actually
changed it wasn't as bad as it currently
is and a lot of people are quite out of
touch here's a great one by jeff melnick
wow that was a long nap think i'll pick
up my phd diploma and go take a walk
around campus here in 1961
right
there's another one perhaps i'm living
in a parallel universe but great
work-life balance in academia freedom
fun
this may have been true 20 years ago
i understand why people prefer industry
to academia and i would probably do the
same if i could turn the clock back
here's another one from drew late to
this but the idea that becoming a
professor is just an option that one
might choose among ex others that are on
the table infuriates because that's not
how the labor pool works and it hasn't
worked that way for a really
really long time that you know and
that's quite true
back when i was a graduate student
coming out of graduate school with my
phd there was already incredible
competition
for the jobs that were available
much of it was a matter of luck or
prestige or having been the right person
in the right place at the right time and
not a matter of merit whatsoever and
that was you know now going on 20 years
here's another one this thread is why i
struggle giving advice to students this
is a very important issue academia today
in academia even five to ten years ago
are not at all the same i've had great
mentors but i've also heard way way too
much terrible advice from senior people
who don't know what the job market is
like who don't understand what current
academic positions are like for people
who are not tenured uh you know advanced
career professors
here's another good
follow-up and this is a caution
that we should be
paying attention to
the quote tweets are making fun of how
absurdly out of touch this threat is
but
this is what every prospective phd
student will be getting told at their
recruitment weekends we need to change
what we're telling people
going into academia we also need to
change the perception that if you
leave with your phd and you're not
getting a teaching position somehow
you've failed rather than the system is
broken down or that if you leave for
some other job that you're you know
abandoning the life of the mind and
unfortunately there's still this toxic
culture going on there
finally here are some interesting
observations
yes it's wonderful and unique academia
which is why there are 10 or 100 or a
thousand candidates for every opening
it's closer to a thousand than it is to
a hundred
and in a competitive field luck becomes
the dominating factor in success
if you have tenure
consider yourself as having won the
lottery and have some humility
that's a great bit of advice if you're
benefiting from things then maybe don't
you know act as if it's a meritocracy
and everybody's got an equal chance if
they just apply themselves because
you're just perpetuating
a lie and a lie that's damaging to so
many people
here's another one my feed is full of
people leaving academia because
academics like this
rather take advantage of their privilege
in hostile institutions for money esteem
and power
rather than help those institutions
become more inclusive
if you have a tenure track position
especially if you're being hired you
know as a chair
then you probably have some let's call
it
moral duties there are some things
incumbent upon you to
better the institution and better the
people who are worse off within the
institution rather than simply taking
advantage of how nice it is for you and
all the opportunities and prestige but
what do we see instead
very few tenure track professors do the
right thing
here's another one i love my job but
there's so much luck in being able to
realize the things you mentioned what
you said assumes that one can get a
full-time tenure-track job many adjuncts
i know don't have this experience and
often aren't included by their
department in events decision making etc
so what what does that tell us well if
you want to
be good to the people who are doing the
most work in academia the adjuncts
maybe if you're a tenure track person
you do include them you work to do so
finally here's here's another one along
those lines
huge percentage of faculty work and
conditions that are nothing like what
you describe serious question
have you thought
about using your prestige and status to
fight for non-tenured colleagues who are
crushed by four four teaching loans and
those by the way are are low i know
people who've worked eight
classes in a semester the faculty life
you described should be universal so
this is to bring this to a close
it's not just about this one clueless uh
tone deaf professor who is crowing about
how wonderful it is for her and you know
the there are all to be to fair there
were some other people chiming in saying
yes i totally agree with you academia is
so amazing you know and that other
people of course responded to them in
these ways we should think about
how the system ought to be changed and
who ought to be doing the work to change
it you can say oh unionized or something
like that but really who is at the core
of how this ought to change it is the
people who were lucky
who
wound up with these tenure track jobs uh
they're the ones who should be
doing the the the real work in making
things better for their colleagues so
i'll just leave that there and you can
ponder this thread you can easily find
it on twitter just by putting in some of
the people's names and doing a search
and hopefully this has given you some
food for thought
you